with very little money you've built up a
nice portfolio how much on average would
you say you're making from the deal
selling twenty thousand pounds wow got
one in London and then the restaurant in
Hertfordshire how much does that make
profit across the five it's about five
thousand a month are you surprised that
you're making 20 grand plus you've got
500 to rent I'm not surprised but I'm
surprised how quick it's taken from
watching a YouTube video to go into a
pound crash course to sit in this chair
today it's been such a journey you've
given us the blueprints all we've done
is taken action
well thanks for coming down to my house
welcome to winners on a Wednesday gav
and Mitch you are identical twins so
it's been difficult for me mentoring you
to know the difference between the two
of you bought it you just give us a
snapshot let's do your backgrounds and
why you decided to get into property our
story is pretty much identical we
started school got to a level both got
kicked out at 6 16 17. yeah yeah we both
got taken into the same office and the
head teach basically said one of you got
three use one of you got three uses an e
so you're both getting kicked out so if
we left school
same day same clothes pictures left and
then we ended up doing recruitment
together yeah recruitment was good fun I
think recruitment was the the starting
point of my sales Journey
um just sitting there constantly up and
down the blower all day
um getting a lot of rejection where
everyone around you is doing the
placements and you know it's like a
sales office everyone's up there ringing
the bells drawing on the boards doing
deals so you kind of you got shaped very
very quickly I needed that for a year
and then I uh went traveling I left the
country got fed up so whilst he was
traveling that year I was still working
in recruitment progressed the way up and
then I was getting paid 150 pounds a
week which was ridiculous I was just
grafting living at home and then he went
traveling and we've got an older brother
who's actually in Australia at the
minute so I decided after that whole
year I'll go travel Australia and meet
Mitch for a month meet my older brother
for a month and then travel for a month
and then that three month holiday turn
into a four-year trip so when we met
then where were you living and what were
you doing when we met about sort of six
months ago I just got back to the UK
when we decided we were going to come
back I was still working gav hung up his
uh through his threw his towel and hung
up his boots
um a few months earlier and started
doing loads of research we all he knew
that we needed to come back fundamental
start a business that will generate a
monthly cash flow and move towards the
high ticket items
um just so we were doing a lot of work
for a very small profit um over in
Australia so then gave did loads of
research came across you on YouTube and
then when we came back I was literally
in the country for maybe three four
weeks when we came to a crash course
yeah started from there so why did you
choose property then so you spent a lot
of time researching what business to
enter you wanted to get into something
that was high ticket where you get paid
High sums of money yeah what was it
about property that made you come to the
crash course yeah I've always wanted to
get into property and I've watched loads
of property stuff and I wanted to get
into flips but when I got to the end of
my Australian experience I kind of just
reviewed everything because I had quite
a bit of time and I noticed that the
products we were selling the CEOs with
the owners were getting paid on some
sort of subscription so I needed to find
something that paid me monthly I was
looking obviously into London the rates
the bills everything was so expensive so
I needed business and then over there we
had a mentor so that was the third goal
I needed to find a mentor when we got
back to start the journey and to
progress through so I started youtubing
and I thought property pays you monthly
you also could build wealth with
property and we found a mental within
property so Mitch came back from work it
was actually Evan's Financial Freedom
challenge I was watching that's what got
me into it and then when Mitch got back
from work he was like what are you
watching I was like honestly I don't
actually know but just sit down and
watch it it's like it's incredible it's
just done and then I had to re-watch it
with Mitch from the beginning and it
started to make sense and then when we
got back we came to the one pound crash
course
and then we got into it straight from
there yeah haven't looked back because I
think with properties there's a lot of
way you can make money you can as you
mentioned you can flip properties but I
do upsell you can also trade properties
so package it and sell it before you've
even owned it like deal sourcing which
is what you've done quite successfully
and control properties subscription
model yeah almost with boxes so why
don't you just talk about you know what
what strategy you decided to do and
maybe talk us through your first deal
and how long it took to get your first
deal from when you met me came to the
crash course and went and went for
lighting property for for me out because
I've traveled quite a lot I've stayed in
shared houses and I've also said in
really luxury airbnbs in the middle of a
jungle on the beach and I just loved
that that service that you provide um in
like service correlation airbnbs
um so that's the route we went there so
what what is service accommodation and
what is rent to service accommodation
how does it work well rent service
accommodation is where you rent a
property from a landlord or an owner a
vendor and you take it on through your
company as a corporate let and then you
turn it um into an Airbnb or rent it out
on Airbnb at bookings.com yeah fully
furnished all your bills are paid for
um you charge a premium on a nightly
basis instead of renting it on a monthly
on a monthly basis to your clients or
your guests but why would a landlord
rent their property to you
even if you were prepared to pay the
full Market rent when then they know
that you're just gonna put it on Airbnb
have guests in and out trailing through
the property wear and tear on the
carpets why would our Lord agree to that
um so there's multiple reasons most
importantly it's just hands off
obviously at a company we're going to
take on the maintenance and keep the the
level of the property at its highest
um and for the landlord they just don't
really do anything they just get paid
guaranteed rent for a long period of
time
um and they're happy we're happy and
then the guests are happy yeah I mean
the landlords we work with they just
love the aspect that we are maintaining
the property we do get cleaners before
and after every guest as well
um and this is hassle free they've never
needed to chase us for rent and make
sure the bills are paid um anything the
second something goes wrong we'll be
there to fix it and we haven't had any
major problems to be honest
um I don't spend much time on them to be
honest yeah maybe like 15-20 minutes a
week
yeah so you can spend about 15 minutes
managing five properties yeah and their
service to combination yeah yeah how do
you systemize it how do you find the
guests and check them in how does the
whole process work the main thing is
when we when we first started we kept on
getting these bookings and realizing
that there were from companies
um so we would call the guest
um the amount of time we've facetimed
the guests as well just to introduce
ourselves they're showing us around the
property hey I love the property and we
just built that relationship with the
guests the people that book it and then
the Neighbors on either side as well
because they're neighbors
um once you put in a good word and they
like you their family will come and
visit one of our neighbors
um is from Finland and their family
comes over all the time and they book it
um instead of the hotel down the road
now the family comes and books are uh
service accommodation unit so I think if
you talk to everyone about what you're
doing you will get the bookings but
speaking to big companies
um calling the guests and introducing
yourself building that relationship
asking what they're doing in the area
find out what company they're working
for and then just call the company and
say I've spoken to the person staying
there what is the reason for the work in
the area I do have other properties
um do you need to send more staff down
and just being proactive about how
you're finding guests
um instead of just hoping for the best
and putting on uh like OTAs and Airbnb
and bookings.com let's add to that the
the team that you need to build around
you that are cleaner is amazing she
literally takes control of all of our
properties
um we refer people to her so then her
business is growing our portfolio is
growing and the deals that we're selling
You've Got The Power Team there so that
cleaner then does everything that
obviously is self-checking with the
lockbox but when she goes in to clean
she'll send me pictures before pictures
after if there's any slight problems
within 20 30 minutes she would have gone
pick up the part or fix the problem send
me a picture and then she just sends me
an invoice at the end of the month how
do you build your power team just
generally like your channel manager your
cleaners maintenance it was quite hard
to find it to start with I think there's
there's so many out there you do have to
you kind of have to interview them to
see if they're the right fit for your
business
um and we sat down with her we showed
around the properties and we asked her
her opinion how long do you reckon it's
going to take you
um what's your like feedback on the
property is it something you're capable
how fast are you able to grow or do you
have the capacity to take on let's say
five properties by the end of the month
and she just takes all the boxes yeah
that's one area
questions is to ask your cleaner if
they've got team as well not just
cleaners but if they've got the
maintenance team with her her husband is
our maintenance and he's got a
construction company so now we're moving
on to brr's he is we've already built
that relationship through the cleaner
and then with him and then he's going to
help us out with further projects but
because the clean is going to be in the
property cleaning she noticed something
she doesn't call me first we've set up
we told her up to a certain amount fix
it and then send us the invoice so then
she'll just call her partner he'll come
fix it and then and that's why it's
passive because of the team yeah we
don't do anything we're about to use
their funds and their team to do a bra
and we're not putting money in it we're
using investors funds
um and some of the build from the The
Power Team as well they're doing the
build
with like free of charge effectively and
we're paying them afterwards if we flip
our refinance
um and they get a percentage of so talk
we're through this brr there how did you
find it because that's the biggest
question that I get asked is how do you
find good deals so blr buy refurbish
refinance rent yeah so you're recycling
all your money how do you find it yeah
so we've we're very active at the sense
of scraping all the internet uh right
move zoopla and finding really run down
properties really
um and also because my background is
direct sales I much prefer walking into
agencies
um stopping people on the streets
speaking to the people at the coffee
shops and speaking to people get to know
people
um they end up just calling you all the
time when you walk to an agency and you
ask hey I'm looking for this property
I'm a cash buyer uh what do you have and
they give you a list be like can we go
and see one now I'm really Keen
um they might they get their back back
on and get the keys and come down the
street with you and they show you all
these properties but now they know what
we're looking for it's not the point we
don't need to go online anymore because
they call us be like hey Mitch we've got
this property get your name out there I
think if you the more attention you
bring to yourself the more deals will
come as well
um and just think about your name out
with the because we started with the
rent to rent with the agents in our
patch so we don't go outside of our
patch we just dominate that area so
these agents have seen us start with
rental rents and seen us get one then
two then all the way up to five which
we've got in the minute and then we
started deal selling with the agents so
the agents have seen us progress as well
so all we need to do is say hey I've
moved I'm changing strategy I need the
worst house on the best street and then
they know what we're doing because
they've helped us out for the last five
six months so now the agents were on
board we've got multiple agents in the
patch which just called us up and say hi
I've got this property for sales
accommodation or I've got this property
it might be good for your investors or
I've got this property which is really
run down so you're almost educating the
agencies as to what you're doing
teaching them about rent to rent it's
about yeah and the agency's also
educated me last week I I re when I was
speaking to the agent
um I was actually inquiring about a br
and he was oh yeah that's the X rental
and I was like I think we're looking at
the wrong one he was like no it's up for
425 and I was like oh potentially he
told me the address and the house was
different the same road same price
different house
um and in my mind I was like well it's
up if it used to be a rental and it's up
for sale
um we can go down the line of a lease
option
um and now we're in negotiations or at
least option on two beds
um Terrace House amazing in Watford and
harfordshire wow so lease option on the
table brr going through how many deals
are you packaging and selling on average
or how many um how much are you making
from the deal sourcing side of things
we've sold I think we've just hit our
25th has gone through
um since the end of December and we've
got about five bespoke clients that we
keep always at the five which will
rotate as soon as we Source One then
we'll send that alone then you must have
made quite a lot of money from the from
the deal selling side of things yeah
yeah it was it was a strange one how we
got in steel sourcing because when we
did your training and you got the five
C's we started with the rent to rent but
within what probably a week after the uh
joining the academy we secured our first
rent to rent and then a couple weeks
after we got another then a couple weeks
after we secured another two and then we
were living together at that time and he
got ill which automatically means I'm
gonna get ill so it was off it was
either we can't go out and do viewings
for our own rent to rents so be able to
make no money in December or how can we
pivot and make money throughout the
Christmas period of coming into the new
year so it's probably about what a 10-15
minute decision straight away rebranded
flipped strategy and then from our sofa
we were really ill we end up sourcing
about eight properties because we the
two that the last two was secured were
in a new development
so we've already seen it we've already
done the numbers and it was a brand new
development which means all the other
flats were available
and we knew the numbers so all we did
was packaged everyone every single
apartment in the development and we sold
them for my sofa and where is that in
Watford no it's Hamilton all of your
deals in Hertfordshire a lot of people
would say if they lived in Hertfordshire
it's quite an expensive area and it's
also it's not I wouldn't say it's quiet
but it's not the hustle and bustle of a
big city like Birmingham or Manchester
so a lot of people if they lived in an
area like Hertfordshire they would think
oh I need to move area I need to either
go to London or I need to go to
Birmingham or but you've actually
utilized your patch and that's something
that we teach we teach people yeah to
work on where they live to begin with
and sometimes if you live even if you
live in the middle of a field middle of
nowhere it's like okay well maybe I
could convert some of the animal barns
the holiday let's get Capital
um allowances and get this and so
there's always stuff you can do in your
area so you've managed to do rent to
rent lease options deal sourcing VR all
within Hertfordshire which I think is
really interesting how did you break
into Hertfordshire we obviously sat down
and just looked at the area and
Hertfordshire on a map does look like a
farm until you start scrolling through
and you can see these little areas
um and then you just need to dig deeper
and see why would people be traveling
into this area
and because we were born there we know
what's happening in Watford we know
what's happening in different towns so
then that's where we started looking and
dominating that area and I think that
the main thing about your patch is
service accommodation isn't just for
leisure and just for tourists I'm pretty
sure we don't have any tourists at our
properties in Hertfordshire no one goes
to party like in Hemel Hempstead yeah
it's a small town and there's a huge
Hospital nothing going on
um that would attract tourists or
Leisure users
um so I think once you start thinking
outside the box and and marketing to the
right people
um you will do well wherever it is what
was your first deal and how long did it
take to get it
um our first deal was a rent a service
accommodation in London we were actually
speaking to people around us what we
just
um like the Academy of what we're just
getting into and it turns out one of our
friends dad's
um just had a property that wasn't
talented for a year so then we started
speaking to him ended up taking that one
so because it's in London we are pushing
for the long term over 90 day
um bookings
um so we're happy to take a smaller fee
so a smaller profits at the minute
probably about six seven hundred a month
yeah amazing what do you mean when you
said about you have longer bookings
there because it's in London why is that
so in London there's a 90-day rule for
short-term accommodation short-term
stays
um is mostly on the Airbnb platform
which will stop you doing it but again
it is a rule across the whole of London
so anything over 28 days will be classed
as a medium term stay
um so we do Market our property on right
move on zoopla and we tend to get quite
a lot of relocators so at the minute
we've just accepted a booking for a
couple moving from India so they're
booking our accommodation for two months
whilst they're exchanging and picking up
the keys for their personal house and
what contracts do you use we use
contracts called lto which a license to
occupy so it's not a short-term contract
it is for a medium and long-term
contracts so with the guests they don't
have tenant rights but they're also not
it's not the same as like if you were
staying at a hotel this is that nice in
between right
there's a obviously 90-day rule um it's
just outside that gray area where you're
allowed to carry on working and
operating so important to know the rules
of your patch as well and I mean this is
something that we bang on about the deal
finding Extravaganza which is you know
the prime your patch go through the
rules
licensing planning because you can end
up getting fines going to prison even if
you you know completely ignore the rules
so I mean I get I get I help out quite a
lot of the academy members and I get
that question all the time about the 90
day Rule and I don't think it's like to
be scared about I think it's you're
always going to hit like hurdles you're
always going to have challenges but
there's always an answer to them and you
just have to be creative around the way
um that you actually operate if there's
my when I took on the one in London yeah
I've thought in my head if there's
management companies and their sole
purpose their whole business is based
around service accommodation in London I
was like it must work so your rent to
rent portfolio then it's all systemized
got one in London and then the rest are
in Hertfordshire how much does that make
profit across the five on average about
a thousand pound each about five
thousand a month for profit what have
you found the biggest challenges with
running a service accommodation business
just a random guess calling you up
that's probably the the challenge the
for us the securing the deal was pretty
straightforward setting up pretty
straightforward and then when like as I
mentioned with that bird situation
that's 9 30 at night or something and
then that happens so that was a
challenge that you just have to either
find someone to deal with that the agent
side is also a challenge when you're
starting
again it's all building in relationships
you need to be able to speak to everyone
on the list create a list of Agents or
landlords call through all of them if
they don't answer a call again that's
probably the the challenge you'll face
when you're starting out but again it's
all goes down to a process if you've got
the process follow the process and
you're always gonna well I I think one
one sorry one one um important thing
um when starting out is
the main the main challenge is the
agents and the landlords will keep on
saying no and what we've started
recently in the last couple months uh
with deal sourcing is when we speak to
the agents and they say no to be like do
you mind if we send you an email of a
breakdown what we do just in case
someone comes up later and they say they
inquire about company let's so we send
them a nice email yeah a breakdown of
everything which is our sales pitch but
when you read it it's read as a nice
email and we send it off to the agent
and now the agent we just say please
copy and paste to every landlord that
may inquire and they copy and paste it
so now we've got the agents to picture
landlords and then they just come back
calling saying we've got someone just
bought a property to us they are
interested and what's the gist of the
pitch what did you say it's near enough
this it's the near enough the same on
the the phone pitch it goes through
saying thank you for so much for
speaking to us on the phone earlier just
so you can so we can introduce ourselves
my name's Mitch I run Vaughan Property
Group with my brother gav we've got many
legs to our business but so I don't
confuse you this is the Main Avenue that
we're looking for this is what I
mentioned on the phone and then we go
through what uh rent to rent is and this
what kind of properties we're looking
for so we're looking for two beds three
beds um it could be units or apartments
or houses anywhere where the landlord
will be open for us renting the property
through our company the benefits to this
is XYZ so
um that's stress free
um what else on the top of my head yeah
maintenance we're gonna fully furnish it
long-term contracts yeah yeah and then
we list everything all the pros we're
touching the cons as well to be like hey
we obviously understand there are loads
of people doing this out there
um which and they don't provide the best
service
um
here's a couple things
um are just about us overall in general
and then we'll just talk about ourselves
and our background introduce ourselves
because the idea is if they're going to
copy and paste it all well and good
selling your services but they're going
to buy from you as a person you need a
unique selling proposition and the next
day or when we see something listed give
them a call hey hopefully did you get my
email they'll be like yeah yeah we did
oh you follow up there
the second that you list something
online we will call them again let's be
like hey did you get my email yeah yeah
mate so that one on Queen Street is that
one still available is the landlord did
you ask them oh man I haven't asked them
yet but I will do I'll get back to you
this afternoon do you mind if I call you
this afternoon to chase it and they'll
be like yeah no worries this afternoon
wow you just you have to be very active
um yeah you have to get your name out
right that's how you guys used to work
on a Italian company but also is what
it's about being personable as well not
annoying yeah and adding value and
ultimately thinking what does the
landlord want what does the agent want
and how can I give them what they want
and with the deal selling as well you've
sold 30 deals five of them are bespoke
which means that you're charging up
front without even having a deal yeah
how are you getting all these investors
where are they coming from any
opportunity we get will will speak up
whether it's on the masterminds at
dinners
um the best thing about us is my network
Mitch's Network and Mitch's is mine so
when it gets to dinners or networking
events will literally walk through the
door I'll shoot around the right he'll
shoot around the left we'll gather
everyone's contacts me in the middle I'm
like productive nice put them onto a
list sometimes people say if only there
was two of me well there is yeah there's
two of you so what so you're going to
the academy dinner so a lot a lot of the
investors from the academy we do
networking events outside of the academy
as well uh We've made a group for
hartfordshire
um and there are a few hartfordshire
property networking events world of
mouth as well it's pretty big you don't
know who people know so someone else's
Network can be your network if you build
that relationship I've noticed that
you've done it's really good if
someone's more successful than you
you're very inquisitive and you'll ask
questions to learn yeah but also with
people that are new and they're starting
out on the academy you're also happily
let them pick your brain yeah and you'll
share and I think when you do that then
people start raving about you and people
will be saying on the on the WhatsApp
chats and stuff oh shout out to the
property twins I just got my first deal
and they gave me a golden nugget hither
and when you build your brand in that
way you actually think how can I add
value to the community how can I be an
asset to the community people feel more
trustworthy to do to deals with you and
just buy deals from you I mean you
mentioned your brr talk to me about that
the bra so we've put in two offers uh
last week one of them we're speaking to
a planning consultant at the moment
um just to see if logistically it would
actually work and we need to convert a
basement which is a commercial unit in
the basement into another dwelling
that's up for 2 30
um and it's two stories that will be
converting to to a two bedroom
Department isn't it I think so yeah
two-bedroom apartment
um and that will push the value up by a
hundred thousand
um the build cost would be around thirty
thousand so about seventy thousand
profit in that how are you getting the
money to do all this because you
mentioned about cash buyer and but
you're not using your own money all
right we haven't actually used a pen we
won't even this last rent to rent we
just got we haven't put any of our own
money into it yeah but so we're with
yeah we're joint venture on the build
with the building and the maintenance
team that looks after all the rent to
rents
um there do the builds and we pay at the
end
um and then for the deposits
um we're using investors funds who's
putting the money in how did you find
the investor yeah yeah some of them are
friends some of them are family members
a lot of them come from the academy just
putting your name out there
um some people are making passive income
from their own portfolio and then join
the academy to start again as such
until you ask the question that's so
true and on the academy there's a real
mix and people have got hundreds of
thousands of pounds or even millions of
pounds are often quite quiet about it
yeah so still you sit with until you sit
with people and chat with them and you
think oh my gosh you can't ever
pre-judge or assume yeah so that's
incredible what will be your top tips
then to people wanting to sort of
emulate what you've done with very
little money you've built up a nice
portfolio you're getting five grand off
your rent to rent how much on average
would you say you're making now from the
deal selling I took twenty thousand
pounds wow yeah so you're charging Hefty
finders fees a lot a lot of the fees on
average it will be three to five
thousand pound for a normal rent to rent
but a lot of them we're packaging now
and we might be selling blocks at a time
so five units to ten units at once to
one investor so instead of charging 3
000 we'll charge 15 or 10 15 20 000
pounds for the deal yeah we also got to
a point where we noticed all our
customers or investors were just paying
the 3 000 that was it so then we sat
down we came up with a plan how can we
maximize the cost per yeah what kind of
deals we'll get more money and yeah
so we've got the Furnishing staging the
project management complete management
afterwards if they need Finance we can
plug them into our Brokers and now
instead of that 3 000 they're paying for
additional Services there's a lot of
services in Hertfordshire if you buy a
deal from us in half this year we will
give you our cleanup our maintenance
team everything that we've got in our
power team we will give you free of
charge and we say that to people so
they're not just paying for the deal
they're also paying for your Connections
in the area the cleaners the whole Power
Team the after cell care such if you
want to play like that like plugging you
into a management company did you
helping you outside did you think you'd
be as successful as you are are you
surprised that you're making 20 grand
plus you've got five rent Durant you're
doing a brr lease option not surprised
I've always had it in me passionate and
I've got that that hunger but I'm
surprised how quick it's taken were you
skeptical at first at all I mean you
talked about the power of mentoring and
you've clearly believed in investing in
yourself from the beginning and having a
mentor were you ever skeptical did you
think oh Isis is this property thing is
this really gonna I think most people's
answer would be yes
um and the same as myself I don't know
about gav but uh when I when I first
started from watching a YouTube video to
go into a pound crash course to sit in
this chair today it's been such a
journey and anyone watching this now
would probably think about them exactly
they're saying oh maybe it's a Samuel I
don't know maybe he pays people to come
over to his house to speak because loads
of people have said that to me
um I know all these people on YouTube
yeah it's just like all the part of the
marketing well it's not because I was in
that same situation like a few months
ago and it's definitely not part of the
marketing because you don't really see
everyone's used to going to UNI and
going like working a job you don't
really hear much about property unless
you're in property so I guess that's
where I was just kind of thinking okay
I'm starting a completely new industry
don't know anything about it just sign
up to the academy now what yeah but then
we had your training met the team
followed the process you've given us the
blueprints all we've done is taken
action but I remember the day you joined
the academy and I remember
um came up to me and said one of you
came up to me and said so what happens
now then what's the process do we have
an onboarding and I answered and then
about five minutes later you came back
and asked me the exact same questions in
the exact and I was thinking I just of
course it was uh
it was the other one and I was like oh
okay that makes sense I was speaking to
ibby a lot
um and ibby I signed up with ibby
um and he's been he's been great support
I've called I actually got off the phone
to him last night
um and I hassled him when I started but
that's what you have to do keep calling
keep picking people's brains to get to
where you want to be but I remember it
was the Thursday
um and it was the dinner night and the
only table that was left was your table
with you Tony all the mentors really
next time I'm sitting next to the zoo
and Gathering my other side and everyone
else's other mentors
and I just felt overwhelmed so I've only
just signed up I'm sitting on the table
with like all the big dogs and I need to
ask questions but obviously the first
question that came to mind was so what
do I do now like I just can't really
turn to the person that just signed up
as part so what do we do it's like I
need to need to make an impression yeah
it was a key point is you need to talk
to people you need to ask for help don't
be embarrassed to ask for help the
mentors are there to book as many
courses you want and without you you've
obviously we're in the academy we're
there to be trained and we're there for
the mentors to help so work as many as
you can and go through the training I
think regardless your experience
regardless what you've done so far in
your life you just have to be coachable
every day if you're not coachable you're
not letting people
um teach you
um that's where your success is going to
stop well you've done absolutely
amazingly well so far and you're still
only halfway not even halfway through
the through the academy five months in
yeah so five months in so really excited
about seeing what you continue to do go
and uh thanks so much for coming and
sharing the story as well yeah thank you
thank you
[Music]
foreign